abone ol
bu Merhabalar ben Serkan amca kalpten
Baba sizlere bu kattan baba adı nasıl
kendine uygun gördüm Hayatındaki bu
değişiklik bu değişimin nasıl oldu beyaz
ondan bahsetmek istiyorum yaz oğlum olan
hikayeden bahsetmek istiyorum Böylelikle
Belki de sizlerin de Kafasında bir
kıvılcım takılabilir bir farkındalık
yaratılabilir Hatta belki de bazılarınız
bizim yolumuzda ilerleyerek
hayatlarındaki kendi değişimlerine yol
açabilirler ve ben de buna belki Az da
olsa bir
vesile olmuş olabilirim diye umuyorum
düşünüyorum Ben Türkiye'de waker erkek
olarak Evet edilen ilk kişi şimdi
diyeceksiniz Daha ne kadar güzel işte
harika
başarmış ki ilk olmuş Bunun gururunu
yaşıyor olmalı bu doğru yani pozitif
anlamda bir ilk olmak pozitif olaylarda
bir kol bir ilk olmak bunu vereceğim
Elbette tüm dünyada böyle ama benim
özelinde düşündüğünüzde düşündüğünüzde
bu
Biraz üzücü bir şey neden diyeceksiniz
Çünkü Medeni Kanun 2002 yılında değişmiş
Türkiye'de ve evli çiftlerin yanı sıra
ve kere erkeklerine bekar kadınların da
Elif edilmesine hak tanınmış Kanunen hak
verilmiş Fakat ben oğlumu 2018'in
sonlarında 2019'da kavuştum 2002 yılında
kanun değişmiş 2019'da kavuştum on yedi
yıl geçmiş 17 17 Kocaeli geçmiş ve Evet
edilen bir tek erkek olmamış bunca süre
içerisinde de çok olmasını isterdim yani
İlk olmak istemiyordum zaten Çünkü
bu prosedürleri anlatarak sizi sıkmak
istemiyorum ama bu ödeme prosedürleri
arasında bir mahkeme suç var velayet
davası ve bu davasında Eğer hakim ters
bir karar verseydi benim adıma tersi
kadar her şey diyenlere deseydi Aslında
Emsal bir dava olmasını çok isterdim
Onun önüne sunabileceği işte bakın daha
önce bir örnek varmış birileri yokmuş
beni asıl gururlandıran ve beni mutlu
eden şeyden Başkaları için bir Emsal
dava oldum onlara yol açabilecek bir
olay olmuş oldu bir bireysel dava olmuş
olmanın gururu daha fazla Ben de ilk
olmaktan ziyade
Bizim Hikayemiz şöyle başladı Ben 2016
yılının Mayıs ayında Evet edinme başvuru
yaptım zaten Ben bekar erkeklerin
başvurabileceği biliyorum ama kalma
bakıp bunu da Galaxy aldıktan sonra Bae
en büyük etkisi de elbette ki etrafında
bekar kadın olarak Evet edilmiş
kişilerin olması da onlar bana güç verdi
ve onların yapabildiklerini görünce ben
neden yapayım dedim Bütün bunların
sonucunda böyle bir 5-6 aylık bir içe
yolculuk karar verme aşamaları bir Bu
karşılaşmalar yapabilir miyim
edebilirmiyim den sonra 2006 Mayıs
ayında ben gittim başvurumu yaptım
sonrasında 18 ay kadar işte bu
bahsettiğim prosedürler devam ediyor
onay süreci devam ediyor bunları dediğim
gibi çok anlatarak sıkmak istemiyorum
ama öğrenmek isterseniz eğer bana sosyal
medyadan şey söyleme hesabından böyle
ondan ulaşarak istediğiniz soruyu
sorabilirsiniz elimden gelen tüm yardımı
yapmak istedim amacımız zaten
farkındalık yaratma
38 arkadaşlara geçti başvurudan ve ben
bir Ankara seyahatinde işte yat
içindeydim bir mesaj geldi Leyla'nın da
sosyal hizmet uzmanı tanışmanın Serkan
Bey bir ilki başardık ya başvurusu
onaylandı Artık sizi sırayı alıyoruz
Mesajı okudum ve böyle hani
havalara uçmanın gerçekten ve fiziki
olarak yaşadığım neredeyse yerimden
sıçradım
Ne yapacağımı bilemedim işte sadece
cevap yazdım Şu an İstanbul dışındayım
yarın gelir gelmez sizi ziyaret edeceğim
sözümüz böyle başlamış oldu beni sırayı
aldılar Ben 8 sıradayım çok kötü sıra
değildi aslında ama bana dediler ki yani
Serkan Bey bakın öyle bakkalbaşı
aramayın Bu sıra yavaş İlerleyen bir
sıra iki ayda bir üç ayda bir araya
mısınız öğrenin Ne mümkün hikaye ekleme
güzel beklemek ben ayrı bir bile
beklemeye dayanamıyordum bir ay telefona
açıyordum ya bir ay gidiyordum bizzat
kuruma gidiyordum
görüşüyordum sohbet ediyorum Sıramı
öğreniyordum böyle o maaş yavaş yerliler
yeni aradan bir buçuk yıl geçti ve ben
ancak üçüncü sıraya gelebilmiş Team
unutmuyorum 20 Kasımda iyi 2018/20 Kasım
doğum günüm dedim ki belki bir doğum
günü hediyesi olur bana Ben sıfır mı bir
arayayım bakayım sırada öğrenmeyi aradım
çok olmadı yine 3. sıradasınız
Her Yaşta olmadı ne yapalım işte ben
zaten razıyım beklemede inşallah diyorum
2019'un yazına kadar çocuğum gelirde
güzel bir tatil yaparız oğlumla beraber
diye düşünüyorum aradan bir hafta kadar
geçti bir kurulan bir Telefon geldi
Telefon numarasını tanıyorum
heyecanlandım endişelendim Daha bir
hafta önce görüşmüş mü Ne diyecekler
olumsuz bir şey diyecekler falan filan
derken aşkım telefonu Serkan Bey Size
uygun bir çocuk dosyası var siz yarın
duruma bekliyoruz dosyayı okumaya
on saniye sessizlik ben çok
içerisindeyim ta Bir hafta önce aradım
üçüncü sıradayım nasıl olur iki sıra
nasıl ilerlemiş olayım dedim Bir hafta
falan Bu şerefsiz onları gelin konuşuruz
yarın Peki dedi yani uykusuz
gecelerinden ilk iyiydi Belki de sabaha
kadar uyuyamadım ertesi gün müstakbel
çocuğun hikayesini okuyacağım dosyasını
okuyacağım sabah erkenden gittim kuruma
İşte sordum neden böyle oldu gel dediler
ki işte hani çok şu an ama kapatacağım
dansın diye söylüyorum dosya üzerinden
istediğiniz kadar çocuğu edebiliyorsunuz
bir şeyi endişelendirir miştir için ses
inmemiştir Hayır ben bu çocuğu görmek
istemiyorum diyebilirsiniz sınız
değişmiyor o dosya sizden sonrakini
sizden sonrakini sunuluyor Ve muhtemelen
benim önündeki iki kişi işte görmek
istemediler bir şekilde bilmiyorum Bana
sana yanlış oldu Ben dosyayı okudum
okudular beraber okuyorsunuz fotoğraf
yok kesinlikle dosyalarda Ben
ilişkilendiren hiçbir şey yoktu ve zaten
bir buçuk yıl beklemişsin
en iyi iki yıl beklemişim onay süreci
başvurudan itibaren nerdeyse Tamam dedim
Yok ben görmek istiyorum Çocuğu beni
endişelendiren bir şey yok Peki dediler
işte biz izinleri alalım organize edelim
Ama siz gideceksiniz çocuğu göreceksiniz
Tamam dedim işte ikinci uykusuz gece
niye Sabahları etmedim sabah erkenden
gittim Tabi ben bilmiyorum ki Çocuklar
işte biraz geç kalkıyorlar kahvaltısını
yapacaklar da şahıs kesecekler de falan
ben sabahın köründe gitmişsin sen benim
müdürün odasına aldılar
müdür bana anlatıyor çocukla ilgili
bilgiler psikolojisi şudur fiziksel
gelişimi şudur duygusal gelişmiş dur
arkadaşlarımız buradan geliyor buradan
çıkıyor yarısını anlamadım duymuyorum
kalbim güm güm atıyor
heyecanlıyım Yani biraz sonra çocuğum
göreceğim
15-20 dakika sonra gelecek dediler Tamam
dedim aynen bu şekilde oturuyorum kapıya
dönük Arkam ve müdür geldi ve dedi ki
bana Serkan de işte geldi çocuk Ya ben
yani şu an hala anlatırken bile Tüylerim
diken diken oluyor onu böyle E çok
duygusal değilim diyen insanların bile
dayanamayacağı bir sahne fotoğraf gibi
beynin içerisinde yer etti o sahne
akıllı döndüm
2-4 aylıkta oldum kocaman kapkara gözler
şey kahvenin saçlar beyaz bir sen ve
Böyle alttan alttan bakan Muzik olduğu
belli o zamanlardan belliydi hala öyle a
görevli anneler iyi görevlerinden tutmuş
kapıda
bekliyor bana bakıyor şu an böyle
gözyaşlarımız gidiyor Ben de kendimi
yani Çok duygusal birisi değilimdir diye
tanımlarken o iki buçuk yılını vermiş
olduğu stres omuzlarındaki yükün
kalkması çocuğun o masumiyeti güzelliği
müstakbel oğlumuzun olduğu ve on saniye
içerisinde yani biz o evde yaşadık oğlum
büyüdü üniversite mezunu olduğu işte
Bir saniye içerisinde bu hayalleri
görüyorsunuz resmen öyle bir film şeridi
gibi gelecek akıyor bu sefer
gözlerinizden hemen yanına gittim çok
sarılmak sıkmak istiyorum ama örtmesini
de istemiyorum elimi uzattım sadece ve
Merhaba benim adım Serkan senin adın
nedir dedim Şöyle bir şeyler de çok da
konuşmasını bilmiyordu kelime kelime
konuşuyordu tamam dediler size artık
oyun salonu alalım siz biraz böyle
alışın kendinize bir bağlanma programı
dedikleri programa katılın Bu da çocukla
vakit geçirmek Aslında bağlanma programı
dedikleri Çünkü beş gün 6000 kadar
sürüyor yaklaşık bu çocuğu alıyorsunuz
eve götürüyorsunuz ki çocuk Hani bir
yabancı ile beraber yaşamaya başlamış
olmasının oluşma ayrıntıyı bir şey V
günün sonunda Müdür dedi ki bana Serkan
Bey Tamamdır sizin artık böyle hani baba
oğul ilişkiniz zaten oluşmuş Siz çocuğu
alıp götürebilirsiniz ertesi gün izinli
alalım bir Bu seçebilirsiniz bir cuma
günü hiç unutmuyorum alacağım dedim
Tabii böyle şey çok heyecanlı günler
geçiyor yani bu süreçte uykusuz
gecelerde bitmiyor evde hiçbir şey yok
Abim ve O Kanlı aynı yaşlarda olan
Yeğenimle beraber biz alışverişe gittik
işte zıbından bezine ateş ölçerin den
bardağına tabağına diş fırçasına her
şeyi aldık ertesi gün değişti Cuma günü
de bu elde edilmiş olan Arkadaşlarınla
beraber kuruma gittik yuvaya gittik
evrakları imzaladım ve dediler ki ben
hangi şeyle istiyor musunuz Hayır dedim
sadece üstündeki kıyafetler benim için
okey tür Uygundur ve belinden tuttum ve
yuvanın dışına böyle beraber
yıkadığımızda attık yeni hayatımıza
beraber geçireceğimiz güzel yıllara uzun
önemle bir kadınınızı beraber atmış
olduk Çok değişik bir duyguydu yani
hakikaten böyle Anlatılmaz yaşanır
denilen baskı da onlardan bir tanesi
hala dediğim gibi anlatırken
heyecanlanıyorum Gözlerim doluyor Kalbim
Atıyor Tüylerim diken diken oluyor ve
demek istiyorum ki Bazen hayatta bu
değişimleri yaşamak gerekiyor
konforundan çıkmak denilen bir şey
vardır ya işte bundan çıkmayı
başarabilirsek Aslında güzel şeylere
vesile oluyor Ben o oğlum öncesinde yani
Baba olmadan Öncesinde çok kahve
oluyordum çok kötüydüm işte ya ayaklarım
kötü geçiyordum uzun demek istemiyorum
güzel yaşadığın arkadaşlarım olduğu
ilişkilerin olduğu gezdik tozluk Ama
belli bir yaştan sonra artık biraz
durulmak dingin olmak istiyorsun aslında
bu değişim Belki de yaş almakla beraber
başlıyor böyle olunca şey safında
örnekler olunca verir çocukları da çok
sevelim verdiği bir güçle hiç başvurumu
yaptım iyi ki yapmışım Bir çocuğun
hayatına girmek onu sizin hayatınızı al
çok güzel bir duygu ve bunu aslında bir
çocuk diye bakmayın şimdi ben Okan'ın
çocuğunu onun çocuğunu onu nesilleri
Belki de etkilemiş oluyorsunuz bir
çocuğun hayatına dokunarak çocuk demek
yaşam enerjisi demek evin içerisinde bir
hayatın yeşerdiğini görüyorsun ben 47
yaşındayım ama bu ikinci baharımı
yaşıyorum diyebilirim size
Küçük bir çocuğun yetişkinliğe doğru
adım atmasını izlemek onu yetiştirmek
çok güzel bir duygu Zaten bence çocuk
sahibi olmanın biyolojik ya da elde
edilmeye de Koruyucu aile en büyük haz
larından bir tanesi geleceği Kendinizden
bir eser bırakmak Aslında bir anlamda
çünkü sizin değerlerimizle yetişeceksin
değerlerimizle büyüyecek sizi yansıtacak
Aslında ileride o onun çocuğunun
çocuğunun çocuğu
çok güzel gurur verici olan kısmı bu
aslında
ben aynı zamanda bir kalben Derneği'nin
diye sizin yerlerini bu sloganı var
Sözlerini bu sloganla bitirmek istiyorum
Biz diyoruz ki bakarsanız bir çocuk
yetişir tüm dünya değişir
abone ol
[Alkış]